have you heard that rumor there's this  weird video that plays on its own when  you watch the video to the end you could  take it away to the other side and you  never wake disappeared economy and  kitchen girls if we can save people i'm  all for it I think it's definitely  better than doing listen it'll  definitely isn't achievable could you  help me out I want to save them you tell  me leave it to me hit it all right here  goes let the music play all right let's  style  I'll do my very very best we'll show you  great items and fun beatable crisis you  must brace ourselves there's no knowing  what to expect investigation team let's  move persona 4 dancing all night